[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good afternoon everyone and welcome to
the council meeting on the 21st of April
it's good to see you all here say our
first Evo a live stream of the council
so I'm understanding so it's a world
first for the why mercury district
councils will be live-streaming today so
just working through the agenda first I
don't have any apologies is there any
apologies to be recorded any conflicts
of interest I have none so I just come
to acknowledgments and fiercely there's
two I'd like to acknowledge one being
Jimmy Bremen Brennan and then also Paul
McCartney Carver so just with Jimmy just
to brief I've always found them a very
stylish in colorful individual and he
was a regular attendee with council
engagements and certainly a strong
supporter was strongly supportive of
coming along to those events obviously a
long involvement with Knight to him
really I found him a very fine
individual and was very say that his
passing but hid the opportunity along
with former mayor David he is to feel
welcome in a quite an unusual event I've
never been to her
sort of a Navy interfere well someone
before they were passed thinks that was
held a few weeks before his passing and
I know the brunner have advised that
they looked to a service when we come
out of lockdown as the muon nitch the
other is Paul McCarver Paul lately
saikhan contractor and he's been for a
number of years he worked for the
council and then as I understand all
contractors since from 1982 onwards he
sadly had a heart attack the other day
and passed away but he used to look
after councils road signage more broadly
so that two individuals that have passed
I'm happy to invite anyone else to make
comment if they wish otherwise I'll ask
us to observe a moment silence so just
ask you all to observe a moment silence
please thank you just before we move
into reports I would particularly like
to acknowledge our CEO Jim Palmer and
all our staff for their transition to
working from home I think they've all
done a magnificent job over this period
and also for their support of our
community through this time as well and
more broadly like to acknowledge all
essential workers thank you for all that
you are doing on behalf of our community
it's been a very difficult time of
adjustment for everyone but especially
our essential workers that are making
sure that we are supported through this
time and I just like to also make
mention as we know that Saturday's ends
each day it will be very unusual not to
be at ninety event this coming weekend
and as we know in Zeke days a national
day of remembrance for all those who
have served and are still serving in
those who ultimately paid the ultimate
sacrifice to be alive so just like to
say on behalf of their district least we
forget
in there are a number of Facebook
messages around about observing silence
at your gates or your entrances to your
home at 6:00 a.m. on ends it morning and
I certainly intend to observe that
myself and it may be something each of
you wish to in in your own home so all
right so we come to reports just first
the first report is the approval of a
submission on the draft ikan annual plan
now I've decided that I'd like to
recommend that we lay this on the table
in the reason for there is there's a
number of measures that I think
counselors should discuss before however
a briefing before we're in a position to
sign off or approve a submission so I
will arrange a briefing for counselors
and the coming week or there abouts but
I'd like to recommend that this report
lay on the table and the interim so we
have an opportunity to discuss its
submission more fully before it comes
back to be signed off I have some of
Peter second seeing it by an evil is
it's a procedural meter
I'll put that all those in favor please
say aye
country to clear that carried so III
guess as as just for going forward as
thumbs up and those that are against you
can just unmute and let me know all
right
okay so we'll move forward from there
the next if we go to item we're going to
just take the slightly out of order from
the order paper but feel we should deal
with item 4.3 first before we deal with
4.2 so Jim I was running if you could
speak to your report covert 19 response
and recovery planning Jen thank you
mister Mia the purpose of this report is
to provide a summary of counsels respond
some recovery actions to date to talk
about some of the key initiatives we
have underway and matters that we are
turning our mind to and perhaps if you
don't mind I'll just cover off a little
bit of how we're moving towards level 3
following the Prime Minister's
announcement yesterday just for your
information the report and I'll talk a
little bit in more detail than I perhaps
normally would to report just given the
slightly different circumstances of
live-streaming and an opportunity for
any of those who may not have that
report in front of them just to
understand the gist of it so by way of
background clearly we have an event and
a set of impacts on the world New
Zealand and district levels that we
perhaps haven't seen during our lifetime
we're now and a lockdown phase at the
moment and we will progress to level 3
next week the impacts not only from a
health point of view which are obviously
significant and they keep it out stamp
it out strategy of the government is one
we're following and you know in my view
that's one to be commended the impacts
of the pandemic while and a health since
they are becoming unfortunately no and
to us all and even the numbers included
in my report written a few days ago
already out of reporters worldwide we
have nearly two and a half million cases
and a hundred and seventy thousand who
have passed away while while they are
that said and themselves a lot of our
focus hopefully if with the effective
strategy that New Zealand has put in
place will really be around the economic
and psychosocial recovery that is
required the economic impact
we're obviously feeling those
immediately with the closure of business
and there's been quite a lot of
commentary around that as we move to out
of level 4 to level 3 and hopefully to
an a nearer business is new as opposed
to normal
those those impacts will be lessened but
I think it's important to remember that
what we're facing is a is a pandemic
that and it's a fix that will last for a
number of years and all event in all
likelihood with border restrictions and
shutdown causing significant adjustment
to the way in which the world operates
and the economic fortunes of our
district in our country are very much
linked to the economic fortunes of the
world and my report sort of touched on
that indicating that that the level of
investment package that has been put
worldwide is significant and New
Zealanders really a cork on the ocean in
terms of than the world economy and how
it impacts us I mentioned in my report
for example the retailer Walmart has a
turnover roughly twice that of the
entire GDP of New Zealand in fact about
20 companies worldwide have GDP bigger
than or have turnover bigger than the
overall New Zealand economy so we
certainly are impacted significantly by
the world economy and particularly how
the US economy performs which is
fundamental to New Zealand it's pleasing
to see the Treasury report released last
week outline and what the potential
impacts could be depending on various
scenarios that follow they will signal
though higher levels of unemployment and
fall in GDP depending on which scenario
is pursued how long locked down lasts
and what level of government initiative
and support is provided beyond that
which has already occurred with the
government's already signaled about 20
billion dollars
worth of support package and it was
indicated last week that the Minister of
Finance would be providing further
advice about what further support the
government may provide and while that's
yet to be provided yet it'll be
interesting to see and I think that will
be significant too as to how the shape
of our recovery looks many are talking
about v-shape recoveries while others
are talking about you and l-shaped
recoveries which is of which is taking a
longer time to recover I think
realistically we've got a couple of
years to go before we meet the bottom of
the cycle and in some rebuilding after
that it's with some optimism I think why
my career is position is not going to be
as significant as some others in the
world and because of we have lists
within New Zealand anyway we have less
dependency on international tourism we
have quite a at the moment stable
international stable primary sector with
international commodity prices holding
up and we have quite strong growth in
low average property prices which
hopefully position us well from a
council's point of view in terms of lock
down we've we have locked down in
accordance with the government's
restrictions and while all of our staff
have been well the vast majority of
their staff have been able to operate
from home services have been constrained
but that doesn't mean we haven't been
busy in terms of providing support to
the community whether that's through our
800 call number supporting local
supermarkets and deploying staff to pack
groceries for vulnerable residents
working with community groups to
understand their concerns and issues
while still trying to keep business
running as as much as we can on a
business-as-usual basis via online
services
the council is now turning its mind to
what it can do on this agenda today
we're going to talk about rates throat
relief packages and in something which
is we've been working on is we're
currently consulting on our draft annual
plan or we're finished consultation now
and we will deliberate that on that and
the end of May we are looking at trying
to reduce the effect of the average rate
increase which is currently 4% on rate
payers and looking to reduce that to a
level that is as low as possibly can be
and that will probably be the subject of
further council briefing and discussion
as we head to the end of May
deliberations we're also starting to
turn our mind to what our long-term plan
will look like which we need to prepare
towards the end of the year and what
assumptions and scenarios are likely to
underpin that further we're working on a
recovery plan importantly a recovery
plan that focuses on our four
well-beings
and has a community centric approach
which is the approach we adopted during
the earthquakes and we'll also be
focusing particularly on economic and
psychosocial recovery we're
transitioning to level 3 next week from
a services point of view that we'll see
pretty much the same level of services
being provided as we currently do with
libraries and aquatics facility still
closed to the public as along with our
service centers and playgrounds and dog
parks and the like some things are
starting to open up though beaches will
have all of our contractors working on
our capital program where they're able
to operate safely they'll be back
underway next week and some of some
service will be provided through the
transfer station we're still working
through that but it looks like we will
be
able to accept green waste and refuse
although not recycling at this stage but
it will be a limited activity which
provides which has a physical distancing
so it won't be quite business as usual
in that regard so we are working our way
through it the financial impacts to the
district of the shutdown have been
reasonably significant we anticipate in
the order of one and a half million
dollars is the financial effect of
covert to us up until the end of June
that will need to be reassessed and
further review undertaken as part of the
draft annual plan in the long term plan
so with that mr. meer there are a number
of recommendations contained within my
report many noting the actions that
we've undertaking asking or suggesting
that you request staff to prepare a
report as part of the draft annual plan
deliberations outlining where savings
can be made to reduce the proposed rate
effect asking us to prepare a rough
recovery plan for your consideration and
that will be subject of council
briefings before that point but a
recovery plan being prepared and noting
that we're continuing to deliver
services to the best of our ability in
accordance with the government's
guidelines thank you mr. Muir happy to
take any questions that people may have
thanks mr. Palmer questions I've got
counts the Redmond the stage caster
Redmond Thank You mr. Mia mr. Parmar are
you able to estimate or advise how the
1.5 million loss of revenue and extra
costs is made up roughly so most of that
1.5 million our cost is actually through
lost income things like our pools having
to close particularly learn to swim
activities closing down that's a
significant portion there was also an
estimate May
but the loss of building consent in
inspection revenue anticipating a
drop-off and both applications and the
ability of builders to progress
inspection work and put in some drop-off
and resource consent revenue as well as
it may be more difficult for applicants
to actually complete and finalize the
resource consent application so loss of
revenue is probably the most significant
element with the 1.5 million there are
some additional costs that we are
incurring to support welfare activities
in the district the cost of setting up
and operating remotely does have some
additional cost like the the licenses
for zoom that we're currently operating
under as an example there will no doubt
that was an estimate made probably a
month ago and all probably in reality
take us two or three months to
understand what the full extent of the
cost is and whether any of the costs
that we've incurred to support recovery
actions are recoverable from the
government as part of their support
under the national state of emergency
declaration but time or time will tell
whether that's the case or not Thank You
councillor banner yes thank you mr
Palmer I'm just in light of the recent
change of status for next week to level
3 are you able to tell me how soon we'll
be able to let people know whether or
what council facilities may be open or
available such as parks dog parks and so
on it's pink Thank You councillor we are
preparing a release and we've worked on
that this morning in terms of confirming
what we think other services that are
available they will pretty much follow
the national guidelines that that are in
place so certainly parks and reserves
clearly open as our beaches now for the
activities which the government has
signaled are acceptable
in the recreation space still we're
proposing that because the number of
contact points with equipment such as
playgrounds and the dog parks and the
like that they still are subject to
closure along with our libraries and
aquatic facilities and respective
libraries we are looking at and
exploring what opportunities available
in addition to our online services and
whether it is possible to have some form
of library book delivery then is
currently being worked on and will be
able to provide further updates but the
broad provision of what council services
are available will be will be released
within the next day Casa de poner yes my
second question was about rubbish you've
mentioned the possibility that
potentially green waste in rubbish may
be able to open in the shorter term are
you also adding budget and for recycling
later bearing in mind we may face
additional volumes and once we come out
of the actual lockdown status so as
you're well aware recycling is collected
through two avenues one of the curbside
for our urban communities and it's also
accepted at our transfer stations
curbside recycling continues as as has
been the case exactly where that will
ultimately be deposited will depend a
little bit on the capacity of those
recyclers to process some of that
product and we're still waiting for some
further advice and clarification around
that at our transfer stations we are
proposing that green waste and refuse be
available we are anticipating a bit of
pent up demand for that and and we can't
have it's probably the maximum of three
lanes of each or three lanes at each the
green waste in the in their face that
be open at any one time and so we're not
quite sure about the traffic management
implications of that it is people queue
for their time and until we've got
clarity around that we're we're
reluctant to restart recycling so that
is something which we could look at or
partial recycling cardboard and glass
over to that potentially available but
we don't want to start that on day one
they'll still also be the ability to
drop off rubbish bags as well as has
been the case through level four but
until we just see the pattern of
activity with with a more constrained
access to those sites we're also just
waiting confirmation on how other local
authorities are proposing to provide
service in the space and it's important
that we're aligned with them to ensure
both consistency of messaging but also
consistency of behavior we wouldn't want
all of our residents having to take
rubbish to Christchurch for example if
they were open and we were shuttle or
vice-versa for that manner matter so
there are things that we're still
working our way through and over the
next couple of days we hope to be able
to clarify and we'll communicate that
clearly once those details are known for
certain Thank You councillor it concern
you mr. Muir had Jim just around the
same sort of level a same question
really but on other levels of service ie
we've had the absolutely right on queue
we've had a bit of an autumn flush with
grass and their parks and things is a
the level of service that's going to
happen the ISIS peak that you're
probably going to answer an exactly the
same way as you did the last one but
just would really like to know about
whether there's a lift and service to
get that down by the time we get to
level two assuming the dates
stay where they are and that is an
assumption you know it's a pretty big
assumption to be honest but it is one is
there any like area our contractors back
on going to be back on board for that
particular
little assumes it's my understanding
that I'm all of our normal contractors
who provide both roading and green space
parks and reserves maintenance will be
able to operate they can do that safely
and so things like grass growth will be
something that they will be looking to
manage to the best of their ability as
the autumn flush comes to a conclusion
so yes over the next couple of three
weeks I'm sure that those teams will be
really keen to get out there and do some
work
thank you yes sir duty just a question
I'd like the same issue as the the
leaves that are born from the out trees
and their rights roadsides are we going
to make available something where they
can drop those leaves and teach us we
really do need to make sure that the
still our storm water isn't being
blocked by citrus leaves I think we
would anticipate it would be a normal I
haven't had any specific consideration
of this but I think our normal Road
sweeping activity will kinstant or needs
to ramp up and particularly in those
tree-lined streets that we have as well
as people are able to still collect
leaves and put them into their green
waste bins which are collected at
curbside so they are still urban options
that are available and if there were if
there is a significant rain event
forecast then typically as part of our
our preparations for that key and known
trouble spots visited and cleared to try
and minimize that impact although as we
know with heavy rain of you
that's often it often is accompanied by
heavy wind strong wind and we get a lot
of a lot of leaves shifting around and
moving into some so trying to keep that
those sums clear and if residents see
that the assump
doing a heavy rain have been pulling
some leaves out of a sump can make a big
difference to the way our stormwater
system performs Thank You councillor
Atkinson via the question Anglosphere
just it was actually round all those
things really what's just a task at the
same time is there an extra cost to
these things or is it they played off
against what hasn't been done is they
built into the 1.5 you know I mean I
know that those questions may not some
of them may not be answerable now but
I'd be just an indication on where that
sits with those level of services that
we already have but they've gone if you
like veneer they they will all need some
further conversation with our
contractors and I'm not just our
maintenance contracts but our physical
Works contracts as well there's been in
some advice received nationally which
understandably recognized the pandemic
and the impacts on contractors ability
to perform as a as a matter that should
be considered within each contract and
that there are scope for variations or
time extensions depending on each
particular contract so conversations
have started with contractors about what
that means for each particular contract
that we have in place and at this stage
I'm not able to advise as to the
monetary effect of those and for some of
our physical works contracts we know
that there could be some significant
claims coming forward thank you
is there any further questions so we
have a recommendation
that's been put forward of 4.3 from the
cheer I'm prepared to move that
recommendation do I have a seconder
councillor Edmund are you indicating
you're prepared to second all right so
that's 4.3 which is contained to 34 to
42 on the agenda pages so firstly I just
want to say I think mr. Palmer has
prepared an excellent report that gives
an excellent summary of the situation
that we face here in this district it's
been a difficult time for not only the
council but especially for our local
community who are facing I would say
from the feedback I'm receiving very
genuine hardship through this time we
hit a workshop last week on the council
budgets which has feed through into
their indication in this report and it's
very important that we signal the
direction that we are today I'd like to
think staff for the work that they've
been doing getting us to this point
there's been a significant around
workers the staff are going line by line
through their budgets to identify
savings I think the message was clear
for me our council last week in our
workshop that we do want to see savings
found and in the sharpening of our pence
or of the pencils through this exercise
it's important that we don't make any
quick or ill-considered decisions that
have later consequences so whilst I want
to signal to the community that we very
much want to find savings and get the
rate see the rate predicted rate
increase reduced considerably don't want
to see that there's unintended
consequences so it's important we take
our time but today it's very important
that we signal but that's the direction
that we want to heed also it's important
in the in the next paper that we also
indicate to people that are finding it
difficult through this period of time
that we do have significant options for
them to assist if they're finding it
difficult to meet the rates and there
will be a number in that situation
then we have very experienced racing
staff that would be only too happy to
talk to people and see what we can do to
assist including deferral which is one
of the options that's mentioned in that
report it's also important that we
signal is is mr. Palmer hears as well as
the work that around the recovery a
speed because there also is very
important and a connecting approach not
only for our district that with greater
Christchurch and we have been in
discussion with respect of Canterbury
councils to make sure that there is a
joined-up approach and the
infrastructure packages that were
request that we put through to
government which have requested
shovel-ready projects and we've
indicated a number of those including
the William bypass the sku bridge and
related water projects and others that
we thought in wheels to White River that
we thought were worthy of consideration
so they've been put forward I think the
other important direction and this is
that we have we have shown that we are
experienced from what's happened in the
past but the earthquakes and the early
appointment of a staff current staff
member to the role of a recovery manager
I think signals the importance that
we're placing on that's not only in this
in the economic SP but also in the
psychosocial field and not to forget our
community in this as well but I don't
want to go too much into this because
we've got a briefing on this on Thursday
which we'll discuss view the staffs
initial thinking the in seeking
councillors opinion on this there's been
a lot of discussion about level of Seva
so I think it's right because there are
the questions councillor bonnet raised
that I get in council a concern has
raised as well particularly around waist
that's one of the biggest issues that I
have call me and then in context so
being able to reopen our transfer
station albeit under limit more limited
conditions I'm sure we'll be welcome
news
by those who have gone gone about
clearing their garages and other things
through this time and this I mean that
kid agree myself so I'm sure he'll
welcome loading my trailer up in due
course but look I just like to say an
all seriousness and message to our
community is that we get the message and
through this time we're doing our work
and we will be able to communicate with
you in due course where we get to but I
just want to make it to you that we just
want to go through this thoroughly so
that we come up with a package that's
probably considered and not need you can
net respect so thanks are going to the
staff I think it clearly indicates a
very good position of we are we as a
council and they are thinking as we go
forward okay councillor Edmund sickening
thank you mr. mayor the council is a
billion-dollar business and we've been
impacted by Cove at 19 as much as the
community if not more than some respects
we will have a loss of revenue as mr.
Palmer indicated and the final amount
remains to be quantified we do have
ongoing work maintenance we provide
essential services which the staff have
maintained during this period of
lockdown we also need to consider
community well-being the physical
aspects are only one part of what we do
a recovery plan in these circumstances
is essential and whilst we could make a
comparison with the youthquake
recovery plan this plan will actually be
quite different the plan will need to
balance the potential hardship of our
ratepayers worth the longer-term impact
on the council activities and business
community facilities and levels of
service that we continue to provide the
decision around rate increases or not is
for another day but I would caution is
you have mr. Muir against a short-term
decision which might negatively impact
on us in the future in the community's
ability to recover I sort of thought
short-term pain equates with long-term
gain but I think whichever way we look
at it we need to play the long game this
isn't just a knee-jerk reaction and I
look forward to a discussion when we
actually look at what relief we can
afford the rate payers and what relief
we can provide for businesses and other
entities and a district so I'm very
pleased to report support the
recommendation and the report and in
particular I look forward through the
draft recovery clean thank you
Thank You councillor Edmund any further
speakers okay there's nothing to respond
to so I'll put the recommendation all
those in favor please raise your please
say aye by indication I declare that
carry thank you everyone all right we
now move to item four point two which is
12 pages 12 to 33 and diligent and the
agenda now I'd like to ask mr. Melwood
to present this report Thank You mr.
Norwood yes good afternoon
Euan councillors this the purpose of the
report is to present some options that
will provide some financial relief for
industries from some of the members of
our ratepayers
businesses and community groups and even
some of the individuals that do business
with the council this - there's two
areas that this takes into effect of
nets one of our is the first one is our
rates adidas we feel that the current
councils policy is able to respond to
the needs of the
people that need that relief and that's
done by via postponements and meeting
with those people putting in place
Direct Debit plans that will postpone
their rates out for 12 to 18 months and
so they have time to get things back in
balance the second one hazard eaters
these are the people that renting and
leasing council properties we we
suggesting that our or recommended to
the council that our rates holiday be
put in place
sorry Irene holiday we put in place and
that would be until the 31st of May the
counter the government's recently just
put in a extent you know extended the
rock down for for one week we think that
comes out on the next week into the
level three a lot of the businesses
still won't be able to do business
during that period and with the relief
recommend it to the thei first of May
the report classifies a number of those
sort of debtors that the council would
provide recommended provide relief to
and that are identified in the report
the the intention is to provide a
blanket cover to those debtors and these
will be the areas and their commercial
hospitality sporting groups including
the ones that are they seen some of the
supporting reserves and so forth they
wouldn't be required to put in an
application for relief there may be
other teachers out there which we are
not aware of the circumstances and we
would be requiring an application for
them just to consider the the relief
that we've put in place the report has a
number of options in the ER that the
council quick and Sutter they could set
a longer period of time to the theeth of
Joan herre with the recent decision from
the government to potentially go into
level two
sometime in may yet to be decided that
means they are swimming pools libraries
and other facilities would be open
including parks and zoos we need to know
what happens with sporting groups but we
are predicting that or forecasting at
this stage that those facilities would
be available for use and therefore the
31st of May means holiday would be
appropriate the stage would like to
probably bring back a report depend on
how circumstances change in the future
but that's just a general overview of
the areas in the report and happy to
take any questions Thank You mr.
Bellwood is there any questions
councillor duty develop accounts that
burn up in Council a consolidating that
was being said but my question is please
but those properties that have that have
been used as an ear B&B not the actual
house itself but a subsequent property
and now being rated the full amount is
there any any help for those especially
when I've now gotten family living in us
that have moved in is there any any way
that can be looked at the rating again
and substituting some date the second
house right in terms of the the rights
Airbnb we wouldn't have a business rate
on those in the district we don't rate
like some of the other areas but they
would be their household was suffering
hardship and having to pay its rates and
so forth years we'd want a year for
though from those individuals and set up
a payment plan which could extend out
some considerable time to help them work
through the financial hardship they're
under green grandparents cottage yes it
does it would
Ultra in terms of that that second
property would have some rates applied
to it as well so they would also be
entitled to look at the relief as a
package as well on that property thank
you thank you
so just a question order counselors
Barnett it concern and reidman have
indicated kessler vana
yes thank you mr. Miller would just
trying to clarify that point about
application you mentioned some groups
will not have to apply for a rent
holiday and some will can you could you
just clarify that for me and what
process you're going to follow yep you
know so in the report and section 1.2
we've identified a number of data
classes so there are the commercial
business and community groups the B
hospitality in ones which have cafes
food outlets sporting clubs that used
council property and may be renting or
leasing some of their the property those
groups would not be sent an invoice we
would withhold the invoice and that have
a rates holiday completely to the 31st
of May other trade deters would be
required because we're not quite sure of
what your circumstances are those those
ones that we've classified we do know we
do know they can't use the facilities
the other ones we don't this is where we
lease perhaps be a land in that
situation sometimes it's for the grazing
of the their own livestock and we're not
sure of those circumstances so they
would have to contact the council and
put a payment plan in place and just
outline what the circumstances are and
just the supplementary question on there
and even should we go to level 2 some of
these businesses may not see a return to
business as usual
will we be considering through their
options going forward and and also when
you say rent holiday does that mean
they're not paying any rent at all or
that they have to pay it later no it's a
complete
no payment at all so we know that they
the business or the function can't exist
we know sporting groups can actually get
fundraising so no there's no payment
required I understand in some commercial
ureas we're they're leasing they have
put on a 50% discount on the rent but in
our situation I think it's it's more
appropriate we just give a complete
green holiday because they don't have
any income they don't have any basis and
they can't use the facility so it means
that it's it's just but a bit more
appropriate should circumstances change
which you're alluding to then we would
need to bring back a further report to
the council as I understand it we've got
the community recreation are looking at
a number of sporting groups and
community groups using our facilities
and they're working with them at the
moment just to see what their
expectations are of the use of their
facilities Thank You councillor van
Calla answer my questions be now sir
Thank You mr. Lee Thank You councillor
Edmund just unmute myself chief do we
have any data on how many people of lost
their jobs in the district and how many
businesses have been forced to close
during the shutdown period I saw
somewhere reference that E&C may have
carried out a survey but I haven't seen
any results yes you use this curry
against you have done a people to work
in that area working some of the
businesses and so forth to see how they
can assist them
sorry point of order mr. chair this is
does not seem to relate to the report
that we receive in well broadly I'm
happy to allow it because it's asking a
question around the position of here I
may be to allow the question
I'm not able to provide those those
those actual numbers I'm not sure the
chief executive has those numbers but we
are aware that as we progress through
this there we are not gonna fix as well
and unsure how that how that evolves
some of the statistics that is coming
through some from some of the normal
sources or somewhere we can expect
somewhere around 13% of unemployment
we're people velocity jobs from 3 or 4%
exist prior to covert 19 so there is
going to be a fair bit of stress in the
community in terms of you know job loss
and so forth which we are looking at as
well mister Pam just just further to
that the council is working with
Ministry of Social Development and work
and income support just to understand
what the impacts are and where we're
hoping to have some data are available
later in the week to share with you
about the what's come to their attention
so far I did see some analysis that said
in the order of 40 to 45 percent of our
districts employees were deemed
essential services were able to continue
operating through level for an effect
were true then that probably means that
we've got upwards of 8 to 10,000 of our
community who are able to work in some
form during that time but it probably
means that there is 10 to 12 thousand
who learned and so and obviously with
the business impacts that we've seen in
closures our town centers have been
extraordinarily quiet so yes there are
some pretty significant impacts but
we'll try and get some more data we
would clearly like you we've got lots of
anecdotal stories of people who have on
reduced hours or have been made
redundant and
there certainly will be impacts not only
for those who work in our district but
those who live here and work in
Christchurch as well so it'll be both
districts economies that we will be
particularly interested in that's why as
mr. Muir referred to and has comments
the importance of working with
Canterbury and Greater Christchurch
partners looking at initiatives that
provide support across Canterbury will
be important to our district through
this recovery you can just feel that
today Thank You mr. Poirot mr. mill
would I have invited either to his award
from Enterprise North Canterbury to
provide us a bit of a brief is part of
our briefing on Thursday to update us on
home we're their age in the program that
they are offering to support businesses
with cash flow issues so Heather will be
there and we'll be happy to answer any
questions I'm sure that others may have
on Thursday do you have for the
questionnaire accounts a supplementary
question mr. Muir mr. mell would have
you taken into account the government
relief packages when coming up with the
rent holiday businesses may be impacted
differently and I just wondered if
you're taking other relief for tenants
into account with that recommendation
yeah yes we have the the businesses that
we're looking at giving the relief to
just haven't been off to operate at all
the ones we there's an exclusion area in
the 1.2 we are we have taken into
account with these situations where the
government have provided substantial
relief and they have been able to use
the the facility such as the housing for
elderly in and so forth and so those
those areas the we're not seeing
additional relief being provided to but
the ones where they haven't me off to
operate at all
that's it's a piece to be a little bit
of an unfair situation to be charging
them for something that they can
actually use and so that's um the basis
of the of the green holiday and is such
a time that they are you able to use
that facility we would in recommence the
the payments but once again they could
be a situation where there are an arene
holiday and they still contact the
council to actually give them some sort
of assistance but I postpone it or part
payment for a period of time until I get
back on their feet
that's your questions counts treatment
casts upon us muster no we're just
wondering if you could clarify how many
business those actual commercial
businesses lace council premises off the
top of my head no I can't is depends on
classification of lease or rent so we
know the certain numbers that are the
but we're talking about with whether the
airport Lisa's coming to that Kirikiri
classification but generally we're just
talking about just a bit more than a
couple of handfuls her so about twenty
which would be classified as true
commercial business when the hospitality
area the rest of them would be sporting
groups and individual leases and rents
but we have over six hundred properties
that we we actually rent always impact
of of how much that would amount to in a
dollar term at all the amount the amount
relating to a commercial that the relief
which we're talking about is about forty
three thousand dollars so on a per
monthly basis it's about twenty two and
a half that by far is the issue around
our writing and how we deal with the
providing relief the
and working through each individual
household okay any further questions so
we have a series that we have a
recommendation with a series of
provisions here council regulars and you
can't be to move seconded by Councillor
bar nuts
cows reconcile yeah look I'm loath to
use the term that everybody seems to be
using at the moment this is
unprecedented weird that I think we'll
all grow to hate but it is unprecedented
and it is extenuating circumstances
there are people out there there are in
positions that never knew they were
going to be anywhere near this I have
had a ring from an airline pilot the
other day looking for a job and building
I'd mention that's probably just a bit
unprecedented in a lot of ways as well
but that is from one end of their scale
to the other you know is is something
that that we've never dealt with in
often when we've had situations the
people at the bottom of the run always
suffer greatly and those at the top of
the roam possibly don't suffer so much
it's not like that
in this situation those people in the
middle particularly and those even at
the top of the run have mortgages and
and other accounts and bills and things
that they must cover that's been their
lifestyle all the way through this is
not the a fault that they have either
lost their job or will be in a situation
where they have to support other people
who have or indeed just themselves with
the circumstances and we have to be
extremely responsible in what we do to
make sure that we can help people as
much as we can through this period and I
think that this gives a very good
indication to our community of what we
can do the other parts will come later
when we start talking about what we're
going to do with our budgets and what
we're going to do with those sorts of
things making sure that we are probably
secondary and a kickstart of anaconda
kana me the kickstart will be run by the
government and hopefully the councils
can continue on with their works
programs in a sensible manner to make
sure that we keep as many people certain
in our district but also in other
districts employed as long as we can and
as long as people are employed in and
start working again which will take some
time and I might add I absolutely
support we were at today and we're we're
heading to I think that we are
absolutely for what we have in the right
place and I think that this council
needs to take that very responsible step
of doing what they're doing we can't do
everything and I agree with the
statement earlier look being first
doesn't mean to say that you've got it
right and I would like to make sure that
these measures that we take reviewed and
reviewed time and time again to make
sure that we're in the right place and
doing the right things for the people
who live in this district
thank you can't say it concern counts
the ballot but you like to exercise you
know thank you and yes in normal times I
would always like to see the dollars
first it's our role as a governor to
look at the budgets however we're not in
normal times as councillor Atkinson has
said and so in this case we really do
need to take that people approach people
are struggling people are really having
trouble paying bills and they're not
sure about their long term employment
situation and so I'm really pleased to
see that this report will do everything
possible to a seat assist people to meet
their rates and a demands and will make
their we know penalties going forward
for the six month period it will allow a
level of flexibility that we have not
offered it before and this is in light
of this emergency obviously some
industries are impacted a lot more than
others it's a very unequal pandemic and
that some industries are booming and
other industries are going to almost
collapse so we have to be very
responsive to the needs of the people in
our district and let the government get
on with the welfare of the whole nation
and the economy for the whole nation
I just want to declare that there is
only a small
of businesses that actually lease
council premises this is different from
Christchurch City we don't have a lot of
lease premises and most of ours tend to
be community and sporting groups which
we need to look after those are the
groups that are going to build the
social recovery as we go forward so I'm
totally supportive of this report but as
counsel a concern has also said I would
like to keep looking at the numbers
because I'm acutely aware that it has
rate payers money we are spending to do
these things and those rate payers money
that we need to look after so I welcome
the further reports as we go through
this unprecedented situation thank you
so Thank You councillor Bartlett's Oh
hands that I had indicated councillors
mailings Duty Stewart and Redmond cancer
mailings Your Honor I simply wanted to
say that I absolutely endorse the
position that the council's taken with
this report we do need to give as many
avenues for relief as is possible for
those who are affected and as has been
said by my colleagues this affects
people from all walks right across the
board and we need to be able to be
flexible in our approach to that and I
heartily congratulate the work that's
gone into putting the support forward
and giving those options to our people
when they desperately need it thank you
Thank You councillor bathing's
caso Duty thank you yes I agree with
that we need to wait for word to look
after our ratepayers but we also do need
to make sure that whatever we can do to
help promote businesses to stay afloat
that is really important not only
businesses but now reasons as well to
staff is really important because I know
it may be a long haul but we just want
to make sure that our community can
survive and survive well and just the
other
I'd like to just put on it that the the
Giri farmers and they're desperately in
need of workers because they can no
longer get migrants from overseas so
they are really and it comes up the 30th
of May so we've got those that are
wanting to - perhaps we can go on to a
dairy farm they need to put their name
because it's one avenue that they can
get some X counts the dirty councillor
Stewart maybe I'll come back to you in a
minute accounts the Redmond first and
then what can be two cancer's Joe Thank
You mr. Muir
I support the recommendation and
principle like councillor Barnett I do
have some reservations we have a lack of
data so we're basing our decisions I'm
really anecdotal evidence if they indeed
as evidence my concern really is that we
are pre determining what may be going
into the recovery plea we're making sort
of piecemeal decisions and waive us and
reduce that rather than having an
overall comprehensive recovery plan
where I would have expected to see some
of these measures included however like
the government I suspect they are making
decisions on the hoof I don't think that
anywhere and can know the effect of
putting an economy in lockdown for six
weeks and so we we written at some other
position really so I'm certainly
supportive of assisting ratepayers who
are in need and I would have preferred
that we had more data and evidence to
support them and ANC may be able to
provide some of that information
when we talked to them on Thursday I
also wondered and hope that the council
is receiving the same consideration from
its landlords that we are granting our
tenants so I would at some point like to
know what's happening in that space the
final thing was we referred the 31st of
May
I'd like to City 2020 added in there so
it's not an indefinite holiday but apart
from that I'm not voting against it
because I think there is mirrors and
doing it but I do have some reservations
for the reasons that I've outlined and
also council about any articulated and a
match beat away so thank you
it's cast sir Edmond Kelso Stewart I see
you're unmuted
I am imprisoned thank you and I just
like to endorse what my fellow
councillors have said here about the the
range and the flexibility of the package
that is proposed here and stressing that
we do need as as has been said to review
it as circumstances change and become
clearer the the publicity round these
options I'm particularly concerned that
it is well publicized that if people are
having difficulties paying their rates
bill they need to get in touch with the
council because the worst thing that
happens with rape bills and the
penalties and while this provision I
think in here that you're investigating
about whether penalties can be set to
one side at the moment that they could
kick in and people are unaware because
they are finding difficulty and and a
reluctant to get in touch
so the publicity around these options
needs to be clearly publicized so that
people know if they are in any
difficulty and tool with these with
rates to the council they need to get in
touch because we can tailor a package to
their
circumstances and they need to
understand that if they don't get in
touch we make the assumption that it is
all okay yet it may not be all okay and
chances are it isn't so they need to put
their hand up whereas and that may not
be a situation that sits comfortably
with people but this time as everyone
has said this is completely different
from anything that has happened before
and people need to come to the council
if they are in difficulty paying their
rates thank you thank you just just in a
few comments fiercely just an answer to
your questions councillor Stewart there
has been Alesha calves Aleta that's gone
out with the rates and voice which does
see here options for people to get in
contact if they are facing difficulty
and it does so it's asking and people to
get in touch and all the communications
that I've seen that the staff are
prepared in the communications that will
go out following this will certainly be
making that clear just to increase I
don't personally see this as piecemeal I
personally see this is very important I
think that there are is is an indication
and an earlier debate there are a lot of
people out the air and hardship they do
need to be signal from the council we
are our thinking is and the space and
what assistance we can give I think it's
much needed and it'll give a lot of
certainty for people that are in beuried
genuine Hodge and I've been a number
contact me so I just like to endorse the
reception of this report and I fully
support the recommendation and thank mr.
will Norwood it has tamed for bringing
it forward I think I had counts at
Leckie thank you
we are needed Murcia you're unmute you
were you are good now yes yeah actually
councillor Stewart has has brought
forward the points I was going to make
cover recovering very nicely so Thank
You G FA a very an excellent report from
a very competent team and supporting
it's a no-brainer thank you
thank you any further contributions
rights reply accounts threat concern
Thank You mr. Muir but can I certainly
don't see this as piecemeal I see this
is an absolute necessity stopgap yes
because we will stop get this all the
way through each step that we take every
review and we move on to the next but as
data becomes available at the moment
there's no data we don't have it neither
does the government and they have far
more resources than we have so they have
what do we have in front of us in my
view the staff have done extremely well
they've been working on budgets they
have been working on on the pandemic
itself they have been working with each
other to make sure that we have the
information to make good decisions they
have done that by no means there's this
piecemeal at all stopgap yes if I see
their councillor Stewart raises
communications I think what are the
lessons that we learned during the
earthquake was not the fact of actually
people getting their communications it
was about being kind it was about their
neighbors making sure that those would
never that would never ever put their
hand up to actually get a bit of help
that we need to make sure we get that
message to their neighbors through air
through their neighbors I should say and
enforce those people to come to us to
get relief for their rates if they're in
hardship and I think that is one lesson
that we we learned pretty strongly in my
view through the earthquake and I I'm
sure mr. farmer will will pick up on
that particular issue as we as we go
through as I'm sure that er staff
already have and the the the data that
will come will shape up exactly where we
go I would be very surprised that we
make too many changes to what we have in
front of us today by the end of May in
fact I'll almost be shocked if we make
too many changes to those people's need
anecdotal or not coming from what is
given
is very real and I think each one of us
have had some communications from
individual people who have already lost
their jobs now that is a very real
situation and that's something that
needs to be acted on as we sit here
today not tomorrow but we need to make
sure as I said and I'm sure that our
staff will give us that guarantee that
we keep reviewing these things as the
data comes through so that we can move
the stopgap out every time or bring it
back in whichever it may be and required
as we go so look I think this is a an
absolute no-brainer and I urge everybody
to support it thank you
so I put the recommendation all those in
favor please say aye
contrary I'd to clear that carried was
that you and favor counts the Duty yes
yes so all in favor
great all right so we now move to I have
no questions and no urgent general
business so at this point I declare our
council meeting closed annex meeting
will be held on the 5th of May so we'll
be having other meetings and between as
we've mentioned the other briefing so
thank you everyone and we clear the
meeting closed so just
[Music]
you
[Music]
you